the majority the people that buy these
guns are rich as white people my guy to
change this coffee is collected pull
there's a 23-karat vintage Gucci blouse
this is a Shaq's Mercedes this is the
own meditation pod
this cap is black lamb skin 25 percent
THC the most expensive you're not
pouring in the world what are you guys
did that yeah laid him out but is it
more roast how old are these kitchens 9
days are these gold they're 23 chemical
which is kind of an 23 hug do you notice
card come on man is our man oh it says
it'll she may even come and grab one by
the neck you might read a book
I love the paint I love the details I
love the rally stripes oh my god what
would something like this cost this one
$16,000 doll he took a $50,000 head out
of the banjo right here you like it in a
cafe that could be 20 to 50 dollars 25
bands this comes 110 thousand dollars
[Music]
room in that briefcase so just ease I'm
never even going for it you're getting
it on this is that toes there's the
other side everybody ain't doing this
ready your bronchial sacs to change
so make it the that's crazy man that's
not real they're very close to my hats
with your coffee
all right kids granny like nothing back
why she trying to meditate good night